The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So we've
been wondering
how a gas, such as
the one in this room,
with particles following
Newtonian equations of motion,
comes to equilibrium.
We decided to explain that
by relying on the Boltzmann
equation.
Essentially, we said, let's look
at the density, or probability,
that we will find particles
with momentum p at location q
at time t, and we found that
within some approximations,
we could represent
the evolution of this
through a linear operator
on the left-hand side
equal to some
collision second order
operator on the right-hand side.
The linear operator is
a bunch of derivatives.
There is the time derivative,
then the coordinate moves
according to the velocity,
which is P over m.
And summation over the index
alpha running from 1 to 3,
or x, y, z, is assumed.
And at this stage,
there is symmetry
within the
representation in terms
of coordinates and momenta.
There is also a force that
causes changes of momentum.
Actually, for most
of today, we are
going to be interested
in something
like the gas in this room
far away from the walls,
where essentially there
is no external potential.
And for the interest of thinking
about modes such as sound,
et cetera, we can remove that.
The second order operator-- the
collision operator-- however,
explicitly because we were
thinking about collisions
among particles that
are taking place
when they are in close
contact, breaks the symmetry
between coordinate and momenta
that were present here.
So this collision
operator was an integral
over the momentum of
another particle that
would come at some
impact parameter
with relative
velocity, and then you
had a subtraction due to
collisions, and then addition
due to reverse collisions.
Now, what we said is
because of the way
that this symmetry is
broken, we can distinguish
between averages in
position and in momentum.
For example, typically we
are interested in variations
of various quantities in space.
And so what we can do is
we can define the density,
let's say at some
particular point,
by integrating over momentum.
So again, I said I don't
really need too much
about the dependence
on momentum,
but I really am
interested in how
things vary from
position to position.
Once we have defined density, we
could define various averages,
where we would multiply this
integral by some function of P
and q, and the average was
defined in this fashion.
What we found was
that really what
happens through this collision
operator-- that typically
is much more important, as
far as the inverse time scales
are concerned, than the
operators on the left,
it has a much bigger
magnitude-- is
that momenta are very rapidly
exchanged and randomized.
And the things that are
randomized most slowly
are quantities that are
conserved in collision.
And so we focused on quantities
that were collision conserved,
and we found that for each
one of these quantities,
we could write down some kind
of a hydrodynamic equation.
In particular, if we looked
at number conservation--
two particles come
in, two particles
go out-- we found that the
equation that described that
was that the time derivative of
the density plus moving along
the streamline had
a special form.
And here, I defined the quantity
u alpha, which is simply
the average of P alpha
over m, defined in the way
that averages defined over here.
And that this is the
number of particles,
how it changes if I move
along the streamline
And variations of this,
if you are incompressible,
comes from the divergence
of your flow velocity.
And actually, this operator we
call the total, or streamline,
derivative.
Now, the next thing
that we said is
that OK, number is conserved,
but momentum is also conserved.
So we can see what equation
I get if I look at momentum.
But in fact, we put
the quantity that
was momentum divided by mass
to make it like a velocity,
and how much you
deviate from the average
that we just calculated.
And this quantity
we also call c.
And when we looked at the
equation that corresponded
to the conservation of this
quantity in collisions,
we found that we had
something like mass times
acceleration along
the streamline.
So basically this
operator multiplied
by mass acting on this
was external force.
Well, currently we've
said this external force
to be zero-- so when
we are inside the box.
Here there was an
additional force
that came from variations
of pressure in the gas.
And so we had a term here that
was 1 over n d alpha of P alpha
beta, and we needed to define
a pressure tensor P alpha
beta, which was nm
expectation line of c alpha c.
Finally, in collisions
there is another quantity
that is conserved, which
is the kinetic energy.
So here the third quantity
could be the kinetic energy--
or actually, we chose
the combination mc
squared over 2, which is the
additional kinetic energy
on top of this.
And it's very easy to check that
if kinetic energy is conserved,
this quantity is also conserved.
We call the average of
this quantity in the way
that we have defined
above as epsilon.
And then the
hydrodynamic equation
is that as you move
along the streams--
so you have this derivative
acting on this quantity
epsilon-- what we are going to
get is something like minus 1
over n d alpha of a
new vector, h alpha.
h alpha, basically, tells me how
this quantity is transported.
So all I need to do is to
have something like mc squared
over 2 transported
along direction alpha.
And then there was
another term, which
was P alpha beta-- the
P alpha beta that we
defined above--
times u alpha beta.
U alpha beta was simply the
derivative of this quantity,
symmetrized.
So the statement
is that something
like a gas-- or any
other fluid, in fact-- we
can describe through
these quantities that
are varying from one
location to another location.
There is something
like a density,
how dense it is
at this location.
How fast particles are
streaming from one location
to another location.
And the energy content
that is ultimately related
to something like
the temperature,
how hot it is locally.
So you have these equations.
Solving these equations,
presumably, is equivalent,
in some sense, to solving
the Boltzmann equation.
The Boltzmann equation, we
know, ultimately reaches
an equilibrium, so we
should be able to figure out
how the system, such as
the gas in this room,
is if disturbed, comes to
equilibrium, if we follow
the density, velocity,
and temperature.
Now, the problem with the
equations as I have written
is that they are not closed
in terms of these three
quantities, because I need
to evaluate the pressure,
I need to evaluate the
heat transfer vector.
And to calculate
these quantities,
I need to be able to
evaluate these averages.
In order to evaluate these
averages, I need to know f.
So how did we proceed?
We said well, let's try to find
approximate solutions for f.
So the next task
is to find maybe
some f, which is a function
of p, q, and t, and we
can substitute over there.
Now, the first
thing that we said
was, OK, maybe what I can do
is I can look at the equation
itself.
Notice that this
part of the equation
is order of 1 over the
time it takes for particles
to move in the gas and
find another particle
to collide with, whereas the
left-hand side is presumably
something that is
related to how far I
go before I see some variation
due to the external box.
And we are really thinking about
cases where the gas particles
are not that
dilute, in the sense
that along the way to go
from one side of the room
to another side of the
room, you encounter
many, many collisions.
So the term on the right-hand
side is much larger.
If that is the case,
we said that maybe it's
justifiable to just solve this
equation on the right-hand side
as a zeroth order.
And to solve that, I really
have to set, for example,
the right-hand side that
I'm integrating here, to 0.
And I know how to do that.
If log f involves collision
conserved quantities,
then ff before is
the same as ff after.
And the solution
that I get by doing
that has the form of exponential
involving conserved quantities,
which are the quantities
that I have indicated
over here-- let's
say, such as c.
And so log of that
would be something
that involves--
I can write as mc
squared over 2 with
some coefficient
that, in principle, varies from
location to another location.
I want to integrate this and
come up with the density,
so I put the density out here,
and I normalize the Gaussian.
And so this is a
reasonable solution.
Indeed, this is the
zeroth order solution
for f-- I'll call that f0.
So once you have the
zeroth order solution,
from that you can calculate
these two quantities.
For example, because the zeroth
order solution is even in c,
the heat vector will
be 0, because it
is symmetric in the
different components.
The pressure tensor will be
proportional to delta alpha
beta.
OK?
We started with that.
Put those over
here, and we found
that we could get some
results that were interesting.
For example, we could see that
the gas can have sound modes.
We could calculate
the speed of sound.
But these sound modes
were not damped.
And there were other modes,
such as sheer modes, that
existed forever,
confounding our expectation
that these equations
should eventually
come to an equilibrium.
So we said, OK, this
was a good attempt.
But what was not good enough to
give us complete equilibrium,
so let's try to find
a better solution.
So how did we find
the better solution?
We said that the
better solution-- let's
assume that the
solution is like this,
but is slightly changed
by a correction.
And the correction comes
because of the effect
of the left-hand side,
which we had ignored so far.
And since the left-hand
side is smaller
than the right-hand side by
a factor involving tau x,
presumably the correction
will involve this tau x.
OK.
Good?
We said that in
order to see that
as a correction,
what I need to do
is to essentially
linearize this expression.
So what we did was we replaced
this f's with f0's 1 plus g,
1 plus g, and so forth.
The zeroth term, by
construction, is 0.
And so if we ignore terms
that are order of g squared,
we get something
that is linear in g.
OK?
Now, it's still an
integral operator,
but we said let's
approximate that integration
and let's do a linearized one
collision time approximation.
What that approximation
amounted to was
that, independent of what this
deviation is, if we are relaxed
to the zeroth order
solution over time scale
that is the same, and that
times scale we'll call tau x.
So essentially we wrote this
as minus f0, essentially
g, which is the difference
between f and f0,
divided by tau x.
f0, this was g.
No.
I guess we don't have this.
We wrote it in this fashion.
It's just writing the
way that I wrote before.
We wrote this as g
over tau x, where
g is the correction that
I have to write here.
And you can see that the
correction is obtained
by multiplying minus tau x with
l acting on f0 divided by f0,
which is l acting on log of f0.
So I would have
here 1 minus tau x--
let's make this curly
bracket-- and then
in the bracket over here, I
have to put the action of l
on the log of f0.
So I have to-- this is my f0.
I take its log.
So the log will have
minus mc squared
over 2 kt and the log
of this combination,
and I do d by dt plus P alpha
over m acting on this log,
and then a bunch of
algebra will leave you
to the following answer.
Not surprisingly, you're
going to get factors of mkT.
So you will get m over kT.
You get c alpha c beta
minus delta alpha beta
c squared over 3 acting on
this rate of strength tensor
that we have defined over here.
And then there are
derivatives that
will act on temperature--
because temperature is allowed
to vary from position to
position-- so there will be
a term that will involve the
derivative of temperature.
In fact, it will come in the
form over T c alpha multiplying
another combination which is
mc squared over 2kT minus 5/2.
Let me see if I got all of
the factors of 1/2 correct.
Yeah.
OK.
So this is the first order term.
Presumably, there will be
high order corrections,
but this is the improved
solution to the Boltzmann
equation beyond the zeroth
order approximation.
It's a solution that involves
both sides of the equation now.
We relied heavily on
the right-hand side
to calculate f0, and we
used the left-hand side--
through this log l
acting on log of f0--
to get the correction
that is order of tau x
that is coming to this equation.
So now, with this
improved solution,
we can go back and re-check
some of the conclusions
that we had before.
So let's, for example, start
by calculating this pressure
tensor P alpha beta, and see
how it was made different.
So what I need to do is
to calculate this average.
How do I calculate that average?
I essentially multiply this f,
as I have indicated over there,
by c alpha c beta, and then
I integrate over all momenta.
Essentially, I have
to do integrations
with this Gaussian weight.
So when I do the
average of c alpha
c beta with this Gaussian
weight, not surprisingly,
I will get the delta
alpha beta, and I
will get from here kT over m.
Multiplying by nm
will give me mkT.
So this is the diagonal form,
where the diagonal elements
are our familiar pressures.
So that was the
zeroth order term.
Essentially, that's
the 1 over here,
multiplying c alpha c
beta before I integrate.
So that's the 1 in this bracket.
But there will be order
of tau x corrections,
because I will have to
multiply two more factors of c
with the c's that
I have over here.
Now, none of these
terms are important,
because these are,
again, odd terms.
So when I multiply two
c's with three or one c
the average will be zero.
So all of the averages are
really coming from these terms.
Now, these terms involve
four factors of c's.
Right?
There's the two c's
that I put out here--
and actually, I
really have to think
of these as different indices,
let's say nu nu, nu nu.
Summation convention
again assumed.
And then when I multiply by
c alpha c beta, I will have,
essentially, four indices
to play with-- c alpha
c beta, c nu c nu.
But it's all done with the
Gaussian weight out here.
And we showed and
discussed how there
was this nice fixed theorem
that enabled you to rapidly
calculate these Gaussian
weights with four factors of c,
or more factors of c--
doesn't really matter.
And so in principle you
know how to do that,
and I'll skip the corresponding
algebra and write the answer.
It is proportional
to minus tau x.
And what it gives you, once
you do these calculations,
is a factor of u alpha beta
minus delta alpha beta over 3
nu gamma gamma.
And again, let me make sure
I did not miss out anything.
And apparently I missed
out the factor of 2.
So really, the only
thing that's happened,
once we went and included this
correction, we added this term.
But the nice thing
about this term
is that potentially, it
has off-diagonal terms.
This matrix initially
was completely diagonal.
The corrections that
we have calculated
are potentially
off-diagonal coming
from this term that corrected
the original Gaussian weight.
So where is that useful?
Well, one of the problems
that we discussed
was that I can imagine a
configuration of velocities,
let's say close to a
wall-- but it does not
have to be a wall,
but something where
I have a profile
of velocities which
exist with components only
along the x direction,
but vary along the y direction.
So this ux is
different from this ux,
because they correspond
to different y's.
So essentially, this is a
pattern of sheering a gas,
if you like.
And the question is,
well, hopefully, this
will come to relax and
eventually give us, let's say,
uniform velocity, or zero
velocity, even better--
if there's a wall, and
the wall velocity is zero.
So how does that happen?
Well, the equation
that I have to satisfy
is this one that involves u.
So I have m.
Well, what do I have to have?
I have du by dt plus
something that acts on ux.
ux only has variations
along the y direction.
So this term, if
it was there, had
to involve a derivative along
the y direction multiplying uy,
but it's not present,
because there's no uy.
On the right-hand side of the
equation, I have to put minus 1
over n.
Again, the only variations
that I'm allowed to have
are along the y direction.
So I have, when I do the
summation over alpha,
the only alpha that
contributes is y.
And so I need the
pressure y, but I'm
looking for velocities
along the x direction,
so the other index better be x.
OK?
So the time course of
the velocity profile
that I set up over
here is determined
by the y derivative of the
yx component of the pressures
tensor.
Now, previously our
problem was that we stopped
at the zeroth order,
and at the zeroth order,
the pressure tensor
was diagonal.
It didn't have a yx component.
So this profile
would stay forever.
But now we do have a
yx component, and so
what do I get?
I will get here
minus 1 over n dy dy.
The yx component will
come from minus 2 tau
x multiplying nkT and
then multiplying-- well,
this term, again, is diagonal.
I can forget about that term.
So it comes from the uxy.
What is uxy?
It is 1/2 of the x derivative
of uy that doesn't exist,
and the y derivative
of ux that does exist.
OK?
So what we have,
once we divide by m,
is that the time
derivative of ux
is given by a bunch
of coefficients.
The n I can cancel
if it does not vary.
What I have is the 2's cancel.
The n's cancel.
I will have tau x kT over m.
tau x kT over m, that's fine.
And then the second derivative
along the y direction of ux.
So suddenly, I have
a different equation.
Rather than having the time
derivative does not change,
I find that the time
derivative of ux
is proportional to Laplacian.
It's a diffusion equation.
And we know the solution
to the diffusion equation,
how it looks qualitative if I
have a profile such as this.
Because of the
fusion, eventually it
will become more and
more uniform in time.
And the characteristic
time over which
it does so, if I assume that,
let's say, in the y direction,
I have a pattern that has some
characteristic size lambda,
then the characteristic
relaxation time for diffusion
will be proportional
to lambda squared.
There's a proportionality here.
The constant of
proportionality is simply
this diffusion coefficient.
So it is inversely.
So it is m kT tau x.
Actually, we want to
think about it further.
kT over m is roughly the square
of the terminal velocities
of the particles.
So lambda squared
divided by v squared
is roughly the time that
you would have ballistically
traveled over this line
scale of the variation.
The square of that
time has to be provided
by the characteristic
collision time,
and that tells
you the time scale
over which this kind
of relaxation occurs.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So if x
depends linearly, why?
Would still get 0
on the-- why can't--
PROFESSOR: OK.
So what you are setting
up is a variation
where there is some kind
of a sheer velocity that
exists forever.
So indeed, this
kind of pattern will
persist, unless you say
that there's actually
another wall at the other end.
So then you will have
some kind of a pattern
that you would relax.
So unless you're willing to send
this all the way to infinity,
is will eventually relax.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you just
say again the last term
on the second
line, the 1/2 term.
Where did that come from?
Can you just explain that?
PROFESSOR: This term?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
The last half of it.
PROFESSOR: The last half of it.
So what did we have here?
So what I have is
that over here,
in calculating
the pressure, when
I'm looking at the xy
component, I better
find some element here
that is off diagonal.
What's the off
diagonal element here?
It is u xy What is u xy?
u xy is this, calculated for.
So it is 1/2 of dx uy,
which is what I don't have,
because my uy is 0.
And the other half or
it, of symmetrization,
is 1/2 the value of x.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
derivative [INAUDIBLE] for ux.
You're starting out
the second term uy uy.
Also, shouldn't there
be a term ux dx?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Yeah.
So this is a-- yes.
There is a term that
is ux dx, but there
is no variation along
the x direction.
I said that I set up
a configuration where
the only non-zero derivatives
are along the y direction.
But in general, yes.
You are right.
This is like a divergence.
It has three terms, but
the way that I set it up,
only one term is non-zero.
AUDIENCE: Also, if you have
[INAUDIBLE] one layer moving
fast at some point, the other
layer moving slower than that.
And you potentially can
create some kind of curl?
But as far as I understand, this
would be an even higher order
effect?
Like turbulence.
PROFESSOR: You said two things.
One of them was you
started saying viscosity.
And indeed, what
we've calculated here,
this thing is the
coefficient of viscosity.
So this is really the
viscosity of the material.
So actually, once I
include this term,
I have the full the
Navier-Stokes equations
with viscosity.
So all of the
vortices, et cetera,
should also be present
and discussed, however
way you want to do it with
Navier-Stokes equation
into this equations.
AUDIENCE: So components
of speed which
are not just x components,
but other components which
are initially zero, will
change because of this, right?
PROFESSOR: Yes, that's right.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: You just
haven't introduced them
in the equation?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So this is I'm looking at the
initial profile in principle.
I think here I have
set up something
that because of symmetry will
always maintain this equation.
But if you put a
little bit bump,
if you make some
perturbation, you
will certainly generate
other components of velocity.
OK?
And so this resolved one of the
modes that was not relaxing.
There was another mode that we
were looking at where I set up
a situation where temperature
and density were changing
across the system,
but their products--
that is, the
pressure-- was uniform.
So you had a system
that was always there
in the zeroth order, despite
having different temperatures
at two different points.
Well, that was partly
because the heat transport
vector was zero.
Now, if I want to calculate
this with this more complicated
equation, well, what I
need-- the problem before
with the zeroth order was
that I had three factors of c,
and that was odd.
But now, I have a term in the
equation this is also odd.
So from here, I will get
a term, and I will in fact
find eventually that
the flow of heat
is proportional to
gradient of temperature.
And one can compute
this coefficient, again,
in terms of mass,
density, et cetera,
just like we calculated
this coefficient over here.
This will give you relaxation.
We can also look at the
sound modes including this,
and you find that the
wave equation that I
had before for the
sound modes will also
get a second derivative
term, and that
will lead to damping
of the modes of sound.
So everything at
this level, now we
have some way of seeing
how the gas will eventually
come to equilibrium.
And given some knowledge of
rough parameters of the gas,
like-- and most
importantly-- what's
the time between
collisions, we can
compute the typical relaxation
time, and the relaxation manner
of the gas.
So we are now going to
change directions, and forget
about time dependents.
So if you have questions
about this section,
now may be a good time.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
what is lambda?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So I assume that
what I have to do
is to solve the equation
for some initial condition.
Let's imagine that that
initial condition, let's say,
is a periodic pattern of
some wavelength lambda.
Or it could be any
other shape that
has some characteristic
dimension.
The important thing is
that the diffusion constant
has units of length
squared over time.
So eventually, you'll
find that all times are
proportional to
some lengths where
times the inverse of
the diffusion constant.
And so you have to look
at your initial system
that you want to relax, identify
the longest length scale that
is involved, and then
your relaxation time
would be roughly of that order.
OK.
So now we get to
the fourth section
of our course,
that eventually has
to do with
statistical mechanics.
And at the very,
very first lecture,
I wrote the definition for
you that I will write again,
that statistical mechanics
is a probabilistic approach
to equilibrium-- also
microscopic-- properties
of large numbers of
degrees of freedom.
So what we did to
thermodynamics was
to identify what equilibrium
microscopic properties are.
They are things such as
identifying the energy, volume,
number of particles of the gas.
There could be other things,
such as temperature, pressure,
number, or other
collections of variables
that are independently
sufficient to describe
a macrostate.
And what we're going to do is
to indicate that macroscopic set
of parameters that
thermodynamically characterize
the equilibrium
system by big M. OK?
Clearly, for a
probabilistic approach,
you want to know something
about the probability.
And we saw that probabilities
involving large numbers--
and actually various things
had some simplified character
that we are going to exploit.
And lastly, in the
last section, we
have been thinking about
microscopic description.
So these large number
of degrees of freedom
we said identify
some point, let's
say, for particles in a six-n
dimensional phase space.
So this would for gas particles
be this collection p and q.
And that these
quantities we know
are in fact subject
to dynamics that
is governed by some Hamiltonian.
And we saw that
if we sort of look
at the entirety of the
probability in this six
n dimensional phase
space, that it
is subject to
Liouville's question that
said that dp by dt is a
Poisson bracket of H and p.
And if the only thing that
we take from equilibrium
is that things should not
change as a function of time,
then requiring this
probability in phase space
to be independent
of time would then
require us to have a p which
is a function of H, which
is defined in p and
q and potentially
other conserved quantities.
So what we are going to do
in statistical mechanics
is to forget about how things
eventually reach equilibrium.
We spent a lot of time
and energy thinking
about how a gas
reaches equilibrium.
Having established
what it requires
to devise that solution
in one particular case,
and one of few cases where
you can actually get far,
you're going to ignore that.
We say that somehow my system
reached this state that
is time independent
and is equilibrium,
and therefore the
probability should somehow
have this character.
And it depends,
however, on what choice
I make for the macrostate.
So what I need here-- this was
a probability of a microstate.
So what I want to do
is to have a statement
about the probability
of a microstate given
some specification
of the macrostate
that I'm interested in.
So that's the task.
And you're going to do that
first in the ensemble--
and I'll tell you again
what ensemble means shortly.
That's called microcanonical.
And if you recall, when we
were constructing our approach
to thermodynamics, one of the
first things that we did was we
said, there's a whole bunch
of things that we don't know,
so let's imagine that our
box is as simple as possible.
So the system that
we are looking
is completely isolated from
the rest of the universe.
It's a box.
There's lots of
things in the box.
But the box has no contact
with the rest of the universe.
So that was the case
where essentially there
was no heat, no work that
was going into the system
and was being exchanged,
and so clearly
this system has a
constant energy.
And so you can certainly
prescribe a particular energy
content to whatever
is in the box.
And that's the chief identity
of the microcanonical ensemble.
It's basically a
collection of boxes
that represent the
same equilibrium.
So if there is
essentially a gas,
the volume is
fixed, so that there
would be no work
that will be done.
The number of
particles is fixed,
so that there is no chemical
work that is being done.
So essentially, in general,
all of the quantities
that we identified
with displacements
are held fixed, as well as
the energy in this ensemble.
So the microcanonical
ensemble would
be essentially E, x, and N
would be the quantities that
parametrize the
equilibrium state.
Of course, there's
a whole collection
of different microstates
that would correspond
to the same macrostate here.
So presumably, this bunch of
particles that are inside this
explore a huge
multidimensional microstate.
And what I want to do is to
assign a probability that,
given that I have
fixed E, x, and n,
that a particular
microstate occurs.
OK?
How do I do that?
Well, I say that OK, if the
energy of that microstate
that I can calculate is not
equal to the energy that I know
I have in the box,
then that's not
one of the microstates that
should be allowed in the box.
But presumably there's a
whole bunch of micro states
whose energy is
compatible with the energy
that I put in the box.
And then I say, OK, if there is
no other conserved quantity--
and let's assume that there
isn't-- I have no way a priori
of distinguishing between them.
So they are just like
the faces of the dice,
and I say they're
all equally likely.
For the dice, I
would give 1/6 here.
There's presumably some
kind of a normalization that
depends on E, x, and n,
that I have to put in.
And again, note
that this is kind
of like a delta
function that I have.
It's like a delta of H
minus E, and it's therefore
consistent with this
Liouville equation.
It's one of these
functions that is related
through H to the probability
on the microstate.
Now, this is an assumption.
It is a way of
assigning probabilities.
It's called assumption of
equal a priori probabilities.
It's like the subjective
assignment of probabilities
and like the faces
of the dice, it's
essentially the
best that you can
do without any
other information.
Now, the statement is that once
I have made this assumption,
I can derive the three
laws of thermodynamics.
No, sorry.
I can derive two of the
three laws of thermodynamics.
Actually, three of the four
laws of thermodynamics, since we
had the zeroth law.
So let's proceed.
OK?
So we want to have a
proof of thermodynamics.
So the zeroth law
had something to do
with putting two
systems in contact,
and when they were
in equilibrium,
there was some empirical
temperature from one
that was the same as what
you had for the other one.
So basically, let's
pick our two systems
and put a wall between them that
allows the exchange of energy.
And so this is my
system one, and they
have an spontaneous energy bond.
This is the part that is
two, it has energy E2.
So I start with an initial state
where when I look at E2 and E2,
I have some initial value of
E1, 0, let's say, and E2, 0.
So my initial state
is here, in these two.
Now, as I proceed in time,
because the two systems can
exchange energy, E1
and E2 can change.
But certainly, what I have is
that E1 plus E2 is something E
total that is E1,0 plus E2,0.
Which means that I'm
always exploring the line
that corresponds to E1 plus
E2 is a constant, which
it runs by 45-degree
along this space.
So once I remove the
constraint that E1 is fixed
and E2 is fixed,
they can exchange.
They explore a whole
bunch of other states
that is available to them.
And I would probably
say that the probability
of the microstates is the same
up to some normalization that
comes from E1.
So the normalization-- not
the entirety 1 plus 2--
is a microcanonical ensemble
but with energy E total.
So there is a
corresponding omega
that is associated with
the combined system.
And to obtain that,
all I need to do
is to sum or integrate
over the energy, let's
say, that I have
in the first one.
The number of states
that I would have,
or the volume of
phase space that I
would have if I
was at E1, and then
simultaneously multiplying by
how many states the second part
can have at the energy
that corresponds
to E total minus E1.
So what I need to do is
to essentially multiply
the number of states that I
would encounter going along
this axis, and the
number of states
that I would multiply
going along the other axis.
So let's try to sort of
indicate those things
with some kind of
a color density.
So let's say that the
density is kind of low here,
it comes kind of high here,
and then goes low here.
If I move along this axis,
let's say that along this axis,
I maybe become high here,
and stay high, and then
become low later.
Some kind of thing.
So all I need to do is to
multiply these two colors
and generate the
color along this--
there is this direction, which
I will plot going, hopefully,
coming out of the board.
And maybe that product
looks something like this.
Stating that somewhere there
is a most probable state,
and I can indicate the most
probable state by E1 star
and E2 star, let's say.
So you may say, OK,
it actually could
be something, who says it
should have one maximum.
It could have multiple
maxima, or things like that.
You could certainly allow
all kinds of things.
Now, my claim is that
when I go and rely
on this particular
limit, I can state
that if I explore
all of these states,
I will find my system in the
vicinity of these energies
with probability that in
the n goes to infinity,
limit becomes 1.
And that kind of
relies on the fact
that each one of
these quantities
is really an exponentially
large quantity.
Before I do that, I
forgot to do something
that I wanted to do over here.
I have promised that as
we go through the course,
at each stage we will
define for each section
its own definition of entropy.
Well, almost, but
not quite that.
Once I have a probability,
I had told you
how to define an entropy
associated with a probability.
So here, I can say that
when I have a probability p,
I can identify the average of
log p, the factor of minus p
log p, to be the entropy
of that probability.
Kind of linked to what we
had for mixing entropy,
except that in
thermodynamics, entropy
had some particular units.
It was related to
heat or temperature.
So we multiplied
by a quantity kb
that has the right
units of energy
divided by degrees Kelvin.
Now, for the choice of the
probability that we have,
it is kind of like a
step function in energy.
The probability is
either 0 or 1 over omega.
So when you're at 0, this
p log p will give you a 0.
When you're over here, p log
p will give you log of omega.
So this is going to give
you kb log of omega.
So we can identify in the
macrocanonical ensemble,
once we've stated
what E, x, and n are,
what the analog
of the six that we
have for the throwing
of the dices, what's
the number of microstates that
are compatible with the energy.
We will have to do a little bit
of massaging that to understand
what that means in
the continuum limit.
We'll fix that.
But once we know that
number, essentially the log
of that number up
to a factor would
give something that would be
the entropy of that probability
that eventually we're
going to identify
with the thermodynamic
entropy that
corresponds to this system.
But having done
that definition, I
can rewrite this quantity
as E1 e to the 1 over kb S1
plus 1 over kb S2.
This one is evaluated at E1.
This one is evaluated at E2,
which is E total minus E1.
Now, the statement that we are
going to gradually build upon
is that these omegas are
these types of quantities
that I mentioned that
depend exponentially
on the number of particles.
So let's say, if you just think
about volume, one particle
then, can be anywhere in this.
So that's a factor of v.
Two particles, v squared.
Three particles, v cubed.
n particles, v to the n.
So these omegas
have buried in them
an exponential dependence on n.
When you take the log, these are
quantities that are extensing.
They're proportionate
to this number
n that becomes very large.
So this is one of
those examples where
to calculate this
omega in total,
I have to evaluate an integral
where the quantities are
exponentially large.
And we saw that
when that happens,
I could replace this
integral essentially,
with its largest value.
So I would have 1 over kb S1
of E1 star plus S2 of E2 star.
Now, how do I identify where
E1 star and E2 star are?
Well, given that I scale along
this axis or along that axis,
essentially I want
to find locations
where the exponent
is the largest.
So how do I find
those locations?
I essentially set
the derivative to 0.
So if I take the derivative
of this with respect to E1,
what do I get?
I get dS1 by dE1.
And from here, I
get dS2 with respect
to an argument that is
in fact has a minus E1,
so I would have minus dS2 with
respect to its own energy.
With respect to its
own energy argument,
but evaluated with
an energy argument
that goes opposite way with E1.
And all of these are
calculated at conditions
where the corresponding
x's and n's are fixed.
And this has to
be 0, which means
that at the maxima, essentially,
I would have this condition.
So again, because of the
exponential character,
there could be multiple
of these maxima.
But if one of them
is slightly larger
than the other in
absolute terms,
in terms of the
intensive quantities,
once I multiply by
these n's, it will
be exponentially
larger than the others.
We sort of discussed that when
we were doing the saddle point
approximation, how essentially
the best maximum is
exponentially larger
than all the others.
And so in that sense, it is
exponentially much more likely
that you would be here
as opposed to here
and anywhere else.
So the statement, again, is that
just a matter of probabilities.
I don't say what's the dynamics
by which the energies can
explore these two axes.
But I imagine like
shuffling cards,
the red and the black cards
have been mixed sufficiently,
and then you ask
a question about
the typical configuration.
And in typical
configurations, you
don't expect a run of ten
black cards, or whatever,
because they're
exponentially unlikely.
So this is the same
statement, that once you
allow this system to equilibrate
its energy, after a while
you look at it, and
with probability 1
you will find it
at a location where
these derivatives are the same.
Now, each one of
these derivatives
is completely something that
pertains to its own system,
so one of them could be a gas.
The other could be a spring.
It could be anything.
And these derivatives could
be very different quantities.
But this equality would hold.
And that is what we
have for the zeroth law.
That when systems come
into equilibrium, there
is a function of
parameters of one
that has to be the same as
the function of the parameters
of the other, which we call
the empirical temperature.
So in principal, we could define
any function of temperature,
and in practice, for
consistently, that function
is one over the temperature.
So the zeroth law
established that exists
this empirical function.
This choice of 1
over T is so that we
are aligned with
everything else that we
have done so far, as
we will see shortly.
OK?
The next thing is
the first law, which
had something to
do with the change
in the energy of the system.
When we go from one
state to another state
had to be made up by a
combination of heat and work.
So for this, let's
expand our system
to allow some kind of work.
So let's imagine that
I have something--
let's say if it is a gas-- and
the quantity that would change
if there's work done on
the gas is the volume.
So let's imagine that there
is a piston that can slide.
And this piston exerts
for the gas a pressure,
or in general, whatever
the conjugate variable
is to the displacement that's
we now allow to change.
So there's potentially a
change in the displacement.
So what we are doing
is there's work
that is done that
corresponds to j delta x.
So what happens if this
j delta x amount of work
is done on the system?
Then the system goes from
one configuration that
is characterized by x to
another configuration that
is characterized
by x plus delta x.
And let's see what the change
in entropy is when that happens.
Change in entropy, or the
log of the number of states
that we have defined.
And so this is essentially the
change starting from E and x
to going to the case where
x changed by an amount dx.
But through this
process I did work,
and so the amount of energy that
is inside the system increases
by an amount that is j delta x.
So if all of these
quantities are infinitesimal,
I have two arguments of S now
have changed infinitesimally,
and I can make the corresponding
expansion in derivatives.
There is a dS with respect
to dE at constant x.
The corresponding change
in E is j delta x.
But then there's also a
dS by dx at constant E
with the same delta
x, so I factored out
the delta x between
the two of them.
Now, dS by dE at
constant x is related
to the empirical
temperature, which we now
set to be 1 over
T. Now, the claim
is that if you have a situation
such as this, where you have
a state that is sitting
in equilibrium--
let's say a gas with a
piston-- then by definition
of equilibrium, the system
does not spontaneously
change its volume.
But it will change its volume
because the number of states
that is availability to it
increases, or S increases.
So in order to
make sure that you
don't go to a state that is
more probable, because there are
more possibilities, there
are more microstates,
I better make sure that
this first derivative is 0.
Otherwise, depending on
whether this is plus or minus,
I could make a
corresponding change
in delta x that would
increase delta S.
So what happens
here if I require
this to be 0 is that
I can identify now
that the derivative of this
quantity dS by dx at constant E
has to be minus j
over T. Currently,
I have only these two
variables, and quite
generically, I can say that dS
is dS by dE at constant x dE
plus dS by dx at constant E dx.
And now I have identified
these two derivatives.
dS by dE is 1 over T, so I have
dE over T. dS by dx is minus
j over T, so I have
minus j dx over T.
And I can rearrange this, and I
see that dE is T dS plus j dx.
Now, the j dx I
recognize as before, it's
the mechanical work.
So I have identified
that generically,
when you make a transformation,
in addition to mechanical work,
there's a component that
changes the energy that
is the one that we can
identify with the heat.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Could you explain
why you set that S to 0?
PROFESSOR: Why did
I set delta S to 0?
So I have a box, and this
box has a certain volume,
and there's a bunch
of particles here,
but the piston that
is holding this
is allowed to slide
to go up and down.
OK?
Now, I can ask what happens if
the volume goes up and down.
If the volume goes up and down,
how many states are available?
So basically, the
statement has been
that for each
configuration, there
is a number of states
that is available.
And if I were to change
that configuration,
the number of
states will change.
And hence the log of it, which
is the entropy, will change.
So how much does it change?
Well, let's see what
arguments changed.
So certainly, the
volume changed.
So x went to x plus dx.
And because I did
some amount of work,
pdv, the amount of energy that
was in the box also changed.
OK?
So after this transformation
with this thing going
up or down, what is
the new logarithm
of the number of states?
How much has it changed?
And how much of the
change is given by this?
Now, suppose that
I make this change,
and I find that suddenly I
have a thousand more states
available to me.
It's a thousand
times more likely
that I will accept this change.
So in order for me to be
penalized-- or actually,
not penalized, or
not gain-- because I
make this transformation,
this change better be 0.
If it is not 0, if
this quantity is,
let's say, positive,
then I will choose
a delta v that is positive, and
delta S will become positive.
If this quantity
happens to be negative,
then I will choose a
delta v that is negative,
and then delta S will
be positive again.
So the statement that
this thing originally
was sitting there by
itself in equilibrium
and did not spontaneously
go up or down
is this statement
this derivative 0.
AUDIENCE: That's only 0 when
the system is in equilibrium?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Yes.
So indeed, this is
then a relationship
that involves parameters of
the system in equilibrium.
Yeah?
So there is
thermodynamically, we
said that once I specify
what my energy and volume
and number of particles
are in equilibrium,
there is a particular
S. And what
I want to know is if
I go from one state
to another state in equilibrium,
what is the change in dS?
That's what this statement is.
Then I can rearrange
it and see that when
I go from one equilibrium state
to another equilibrium state,
I have to change
internal energy, which
I can do either by doing
work or by doing heat.
OK?
Now, the second law
is actually obvious.
I have stated that I start
from this configuration
and go to that configuration
simply because of probability.
The probabilities are inverse
of this omega, if you like.
So I start with some location--
like the pack of cards,
all of the black
on one side, all
of the red on the other
side-- and I do some dynamics,
and I will end up
with some other state.
I will, because why?
Because that state has a much
more volume of possibilities.
There is a single
state that we identify
as all-black and
all-red, and there's
a myriad of states that we say
they're all randomly mixed,
and so we're much
more likely to find
from that subset of states.
So I have certainly stated
that S1 evaluated at E1 star,
plus S2 evaluated at
E2 star, essentially
the peak of that object, is much
larger than S1 plus E1 plus 0
plus S2 [INAUDIBLE].
And more specifically,
if we sort of follow
the course of the system
as it starts from here,
you will find that it will
basically go in the direction
always such that the derivatives
that are related to temperature
are such that the energy
will flow from the hot air
to the colder body,
consistent with what
we expect from thermodynamics.
The one law of thermodynamic
that I cannot prove from what I
have given you so
far is the third law.
There is no reason
why the entropy should
go to 0 as you go
to 0 temperature
within this perspective.
So it's good to look at our
canonical example, which
is the ideal gas.
Again, for the
ideal gas, if I am
in a microcanonical
ensemble, it means
that I have told you what
the energy of the box is,
what the volume of the box
is, and how many particles
are in it.
So clearly the microstate
that corresponds to that
is the collection of
the 6N coordinates
and momenta of the
particles in the box.
And the energy of
the system is made up
by the sum of the energies
of all of the particles,
and basically, ideal gas means
that the energy that we write
is the sum of the
contributions that you
would have from
individual particles.
So individual particles
have a kinetic energy
and some potential
energy, and since we
are stating that we
have a box of volume v,
this u essentially represents
this box of volume.
It's a potential that is 0
inside this volume and infinity
outside of it.
Fine.
So you ask what's
the probability
of some particular
microstate, given
that I specified E, v, and n.
I would say, well, OK.
This is, by the construction
that we had, 0 or 1
over some omega, depending on
whether the energy is right.
And since for the
box, the energy
is made up of the
kinetic energy,
if sum over i p i squared
over 2m is not equal to E,
or particle q is
outside the box.
And it is the same value if
sum over i p i squared over 2m
is equal to v and q i's
are all inside the box.
So a note about normalization.
I kind of skipped on
this over the last one.
p is a probability in this
6N dimensional phase space.
So the normalization is that the
integral over all of the p i's
and qi's should be equal to 1.
And so this omega,
more precisely,
when we are not talking
about discrete numbers,
is the quantity
that I have to put
so that when I integrate this
over phase space, I will get 1.
So basically, if I write this
in the form that I have written,
you can see that omega is
obtained by integrating over
p i q i that correspond
to this accessible states.
It's kind of like
a delta function.
Basically, there's huge
portions of phase space
that are 0 probability,
and then there's
a surface that has
the probability that
is 1 over omega and it is
the area of that surface
that I have to ensure
is appearing here,
so that when I integrate
over that area of one
over that area, I will get one.
Now, the part that corresponds
to the q coordinates
is actually very
simple, because the q
coordinates have to
be inside the box.
Each one of them has a volume
v, so the coordinate part
of the integral
gives me v to the m.
OK?
Now, the momentum
part, the momenta
are constrained by
something like this.
I can rewrite that as sum over
i p i squared equals to 2mE.
And if I regard this 2mE as
something like r squared,
like a radius
squared, you can see
that this is like
the equation that you
would have for
the generalization
of the sphere in 3N dimensions.
Because if I had
just x squared, x
squared plus y squared
is r squared is a circle,
x squared plus y
squared plus z squared
is r squared is
a sphere, so this
is the hypersphere
in 3N dimensions.
So when I do the
integrations over q,
I have to integrate
over the surface of a 3N
dimensional hypersphere of
radius square root of 2m.
OK?
And there is a simple
formula for that.
This surface area,
in general, is
going to be
proportional to r raised
to the power of
dimension minus 1.
And there's the generalization
of 2pi r over 4pi r squared
that you would have in
two or three dimensions,
which we will discuss next time.
It is 2 to the
power of 3n over 2
divided by 3n over 2 factorial.
So we have the formula
for this omega.
We will re-derive it and
discuss it next time.